إنه نفس الشيء
[موسيقى]
يقول
إنها كانت أيامًا مخيفة للغاية في كل مرة
سمعنا فيها قنبلة قفزت من سريري للذهاب
إلى والدتي ،
وهو يقول
أنني أتمنى حقًا أن أرتاح أو أن
يساعدني طبيب نفساني مثل الآخرين
في العالم  الذين يعانون من الحروب ولكن
هذه أمنيات فقط
هنا أقف من الساعة التاسعة صباحًا
لتأمين الطعام لعائلتي
، يبدأ الصبي في البكاء في الحال
أنا حزين وخائف ومتعب ، أريد فقط أن
أنام دون ذعر أو قنابل فوق رأسي
[موسيقى  ]
[موسيقى]
كانت الأخبار مليئة بالأطفال الذين
قُتلوا ، وشاهدت صورهم على
وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي ووضعت نفسي
مكانهم تخيلت أن الحرب تقتل الأطفال ،
ولا أريد أن تعاني أمي مثل
أمهات الأطفال الذين كانوا  قتلت
لا أريد أن أحطم قلبي أريد أن
أبقى حيا غير ممزق في غارة جوية إسرائيلية
ما خطب الإسرائيليين ما خطبهم
أنت